nestled in the pembrokeshire coastline
the village of sulphur is one of wells's
most stunning spots
but amid the beauty is anger
around 75 of properties in the lower
part of this village
are second homes and holiday lets
frustrating for locals
who say in the winter it's like a ghost
town wales isn't a theme park you know
people genuinely live here
and that's this is where our lives are
um you know we're not a tourist
attraction to be gaupped at in a sense
and it is it's becoming increasingly
difficult for young people to stay
locally
um and and live in those communities
that their parents lived in
the problem is now so bad the welsh
government will this summer trial
new measures they include a possible
limit on holiday homes
and giving councils the power to raise
taxes
a few years ago wales became the first
country in the uk
to allow its local authorities to charge
second home owners
a council tax premium it's 50
here in pembrokeshire the money is to be
used to build affordable homes
and there are plans to construct 18 of
them here in this old playing field
hi my name is rachel and this is where
i've been living for the past
nine months for 25 year old rachel this
static caravan
is her home born and bred in silver
there just aren't any houses for people
like her
it's just frustrating more than anything
because i'm there's so many of us in the
same situation
so many of my friends either having to
move areas to get on the housing ladder
or also living in some forms of
temporary accommodations some in yurts
other caravans around the area and it's
just really frustrating to feel like
we'll come back and we want to support
the economy
and hopefully you know build families
here and so on and it's just not
possible for us this time because
second home owners are pricing us out
wales
is building new homes but it takes time
the minister in charge
says there's no silver bullet we're
absolutely determined to build the kind
of
community and cooperative housing and
also the social housing that gets people
a warm comfortable secure home we live
in a very beautiful place it's very
attractive to people
but we also want them to be vibrant
sustainable communities
full of people who want to live work and
stay here
for those in desperate need of housing
there is no time to waste
the welsh government says it'll
introduce the new measures
this autumn dan white has sky news in
solver
pembrokeshire
you